OKCREEPY
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: NOT ONLY DOES
OKCUPID HELP YOU FIND ROMANCE IT
ALSO HELPS REMIND YOU JUST HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE WALKING RED
FLAGS.
ONE CATEGORY TO AN OKCUPID
PROFILE IS THE FIRST THING
PEOPLE USUALLY NOTICE ABOUT ME.
SO I AM GOING TO SHOW YOU A REAL
OKCUPID PROFILE AND YOU
BUZZ IN AND TELL ME WHAT IT
SHOULD SAY.
HERE'S THE FIRST ONE. LESLEY
STALLION.
>> YES, RON
>> A SURPRISING AMOUNT OF
DR. PEPPER BOTTLE CAPS UNDER
MY CLEAVAGE.
>> POINTS.
>> THAT GUY KNOWS HOW TO LIVE,
THOUGH.
>> NOT FOR MUCH LONGER.
>> NICE.
GREAT TEAMWORK.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE. DIAPERED
COLIN.
THIS IS DIAPERED COLIN.
>> OH. YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
LEAVE THAT HOUSE ALIVE.
>> Chris: RICK.
>> DON'T LET THE MASK FOOL YOU I
AM ACTUALLY AN INCREDIBLY INSANE
PERSON.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
BRENT.
>> I THINK THE FIRST THING
YOU'LL NOTICE ABOUT ME IS
MY PHOTOGRAPHY COLLECTION.
>> Chris: POINTS. GOOD ONE.
EXCELLENT.
>> AND HERE'S THE LAST
ONE, SHARPIE EYEBROW.
SHARPIE EYEBROW.
>> KILL IT WITH FIRE!
>> I AM CHRIS ANGEL.